what is going on everybody welcome to
part two of our base map or geographical
plotting within python tutorial where we
left off we were just making a really
really simple projection not too fancy
no plots but we just putting up the
world basically so it looks good so far
now just so you guys this might sound
kind of goofy but we probably should
have a quick reminder about latitude and
longitude so latitude is running up and
down right vertically longitude runs
long so left to right so longitude is
your X variable latitude is in theory
your Y variable right X runs left right
Y runs up and down but most of the time
when a latitude and longitude is
reported it's reporting that port right
latitude longitude so it's actually
being reported Y X so just kind of start
messing around with that in your head
for a little bit because when we finally
get to that it's just good to keep
yourself oriented and also the way this
works if you didn't already figure it
out normally coordinates are given in
north south east west right so your
north coordinates are the positives
south coordinate is obviously in the
negatives West coordinate is also
negatives and east coordinate is it
positive so you can think of it as you
know a plane right that's kind of the
idea we are actually plotting stuff and
we're treating it like a plane so just
keep that in mind so now that we have
made a really really basic map let's go
over some of the stuff that we can
customize real quick so before changing
anything resolution C stands for crude
resolution and then the other one is L
for a low resolution and an H for high
depending on what you want to do you
might want to change those up but just
to show you guys so if we did L you have
already seen C L it's going to take a
little bit slightly longer but as you
can see it drew some stuff
within our continents basically it's
like lakes and like large lakes are now
being shown and then finally you can
draw the H but mind you it's going to
take a little bit to render this but
we'll wait and we wait wow you're still
waiting it's very long on process
they've already pop-up for us or not no
still waiting but anyway I guess I'll
explain the you know high granulated
part of our problem is we're plotting
like the entire earth right now but the
higher you go obviously the more detail
of the map you're going to have so
anyway here's our new one so as you can
see it's done a lot of lakes and stuff
for us so like now we can zoom back into
like the Canada region that we were just
looking at a little bit ago yeah there's
a lot more detail there but obviously
this is taking up a lot of loading time
so if you don't need that stuff you
shouldn't really use it so anyway we're
not going to use it but it's there just
in case that's what you wanted I'm gonna
use crude now the next thing that we
were talking about more latitude and
longitude right now we're showing you
know the whole earth right and maybe
we're just interested in for now the
United States region right so you
wouldn't want to have to zoom in every
time to the United States so what you
can start to do is cut this stuff so
like in the lower left corner 60 degrees
the upper right can stay at 90 then we'd
want to do well let's just do this real
quick just to keep you guys oriented so
like we can cut away the south you know
you know so like unless you really want
Antarctica you just you don't need
Antarctica so you might as well cut that
away we'll zoom into the rest of America
later so the next thing that we can also
do is on the fil continents you can
choose colors so you can choose the
continent color and you can choose the
lake color and then also the boundaries
you can choose color there as well so
for example fill continent so you can
say color equals and you can either use
hex colors or you
you's like the red-green-blue that kind
of stuff but we're going to use a zero
seven two B five seven and then you can
specify the lake color and that will
just be F F that is white next thing you
can do is fill the water so where we
have draw map boundary you can do fill
color equals and again we're just going
to color all the water the same as we F
so now when we render this up you can
see now our continent is dark blue and
all the water is white so it looks you
know slightly better than it was looking
so that's going to conclude this
tutorial in the next tutorial I'll be
showing you guys how to draw state lines
country lines and even make your
projection and quite a bit cooler even
though we're not actually going to use
it it's still pretty cool to show you
and some of you guys might actually
enjoy it so I'll show you another cool
projection that you can do so anyway as
always thanks for watching thanks for
your support your subscriptions and
until next